Speaker 1: . All right, so as we went into the
long Thanksgiving weekend in the United States,
Donald Trump gave an interview to
Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity,
and I think this interview is interesting because
if they're I'm worried there are already some
people becoming desensitized to how horrible it
was under Trump, where some people are already
starting to forget and saying, I don't know,
Biden is not super exciting. And was Trump
really that bad? And it's very, very concerning.
And what is notable about this interview is
the degree to which Donald Trump's same old
lies are being repeated but made even worse,
and whether where his same terrible instincts
are being escalated and blown up even further.
Just look at this first clip Trump with further
lies, further lies about gas prices. Two weeks
ago, we looked at a different interview Trump did,
where he lied about gas prices to some degree.
He's now lying even more and being even more
deceptive about this issue. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Gas was at a gasoline, a dollar
eighty three or a dollar eighty six when I left
a gallon, and now it's at seven dollars
and seventy cents in California,
in different places in California, and it's
heading that way everywhere. And it's going to
go a lot higher than that. And we're asking OPEC.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So as I told you two weeks ago,
the real price when Trump a year ago when
Trump left, was to tow a gallon 220 a gallon,
not a dollar 80 or 83 or 86 or a dollar 78. So
the gas price was higher when when Trump now says,
and it's 770 in California again, I wasn't able
to find any place where it was 770 in California.
I've heard anecdotally that super premium
sometimes is in certain places, seven bucks
a gallon in California. Most people don't use
super premium. The average price in California
is actually 470. So Trump is lying. It's just
lie upon, lie upon lie. Trump then again went
back to this thing about Mark Zuckerberg, wanted
goodies from him. We still haven't really figured
out what that means, but Trump keeps saying it
Speaker 4: and you watch what happens. I think big
things are going to happen, actually, Sean. But he
would often come to the White House trying to get
goodies he didn't do too well. Well, you
Speaker 1: have. So the context here is Zuckerberg
is bad because Facebook banned Trump for regularly
flouting and violating their terms of service.
And Trump now says on the one hand, they they
suppress my speech. But then Zuckerberg came
to me asking for stuff. Now, is it possible
that Zuckerberg went to Trump asking for stuff?
Oh, I'm almost positive. I mean, I can't
imagine anybody who runs a company that
big who given the opportunity to speak to a
president wouldn't try to lobby on the behalf
of things that would be good for them. But
that routine, it's all personal for Trump.
It's all purpose. It's not about what is the best
infrastructure for social media, for the country,
and what could I do in my meetings for Mark
Zuckerberg to do good things? It's Zuckerberg
banned me, but he asked me for stuff. It's all
me, me, me. It's all personal. Trump, then now
this is fascinating. He shifts an old talking
point to now generally apply to supply chains.
Check to see if you noticed the talking point.
Speaker 4: And we did a fantastic job in supplying
our country. Every shelf was bare, every
cupboard I call them, the cupboards were bare
for the different states. We did a
great job. We got no recognition.
Speaker 1: Now you might remember that the
cupboards were bare is a phrase Trump used
to only apply to what he said was the bare
cupboards of the military. Trump would say,
I came in. Obama left the cupboards bare in
the military. We had no weapons. He said, Sir,
they they came to me. They said, Sir, we got no
ammunition and then I got ammunition. Now Trump
is just generally applying. The cupboards were
bare to states, supply chain products or whatever.
It's the same talking point now just applied to
something different, and it's always been a lie.
Then Trump starts to try to rewrite history. Trump
raises the idea that the Capitol riots on January
6th. Those were Trump supporters. That was antifa.
Speaker 4: But they go after people that in many
cases and not in all cases, but in many, many
cases are patriots. And you had some bad people.
And if you look at what happened at the Capitol,
you had some bad people that were not patriots at
all. And they came from other places, including
antifa and including others. And they let a lot
of people astray. They don't want to cover that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I like how he says antifa antifa
so that Trump is saying two things.
His supporters who are not criminals,
they're patriots aren't being treated well. And
the truth that a lot of the rioters were antifa
is not being covered and those people are
not being prosecuted. There's no evidence
for any of this. This is lies all the
way down. I hope that you know that
maybe the funniest moment from this interview
is, Trump says. Finally, the Durham report is
out. It's not. And Hannity goes, but it's
not out. And it's just a delightfully
confusing moment here on on the Hannity show.
Speaker 4: Interesting. The Durham report
has sparked, you know, it's come out. I wish
it could have been a little earlier, but
it's unbelievably complete, and I would imagine
it's just not even clear intentions. But I want
to ask you about that. I mean, not with the
fact we know the Steele dossier is debunked.
That's the best.
Speaker 1: Hannity doesn't know
who it is, but it's not even out. And Trump says
no well, but the foundations are being built. Is
it just total confusion? And then maybe my
favorite lie that was the funniest moment.
But my favorite lie is when Trump says he
created the term fake news. Now I'm an admirer
Speaker 4: and I say it, and I don't want to
say it much, but I say it, and I hope in the
future I won't have to. They are the enemy
of the people, and we could have a country
that would be able to heal and get together,
except the media, Foment said. They're so corrupt.
And, you know, I call it, I came up with the
term fake news a long time ago. I don't know
if I'll get credit for that, but that's OK.
Speaker 1: Well, you won't get credit for it
because you didn't come up with the term. And now
this is this is super interesting. The term fake
news has been around a really, really long time,
and it has a specific meaning like the original
fake news. Was Hillary Clinton birthing an alien
baby or something? Like, I'm not saying that's the
first fake news story, but it referred to like
tabloid fake news later in the advent during
the after the advent of online news. Fake news
was used to refer to the same type of stuff, but
online just totally made up stories. Trump didn't
invent the term fake news. What Trump pioneered
was calling any reporting. You don't like fake
news. That's Trump's contribution. It's a very
negative contribution. Then they go on to dementia
and cognitive tests and Sean Hannity still talking
about Trump passing his dementia test.
Speaker 4: You took that cognitive test. I
asked Ronny Jackson, you got 30 out of 30. Do you
believe that Joe Biden is showing signs of being
cognitively compromised and should he take the
test? Look, all I can say is I know President Xi,
I know Putin, I know Kim Jong UN and I know
all the leaders of the world. I got to know
him very well. Most of my life, many of my
like, although tough cookies, they're all
at the top of their game. We need somebody
that's at the top of the game and you know,
maybe you should. It should be mandated that
you take like cognitive tests or something.
Speaker 1: Yes, we've been saying that for a
long time, but the Montreal cognitive assessment
would just be one layer. We would hopefully have
more, actually. And that is what Trump seems very
confused about, maybe like cognitive
tests or something. And then lastly,
Trump says in reaction to the Waukesha tragedy
where this individual ran over multiple people
killing. I think the death toll is now
tragically up to six. Trump says there is
good news there, which is the guy hated Trump.
Speaker 4: The good news is he hated Trump,
OK? He hated Trump. Based on early.
Speaker 1: That's the good news, guys.
The guy hated Trump. So another I mean,
you couldn't get an easier interview from
Sean Hannity, and even Sean Hannity can't save
Donald Trump from making a fool out of himself.